[music]
>> Okay, brother.
Remember.
Surah al-Fatiha, chapter number one, the
opening. Surah al-Baqarah, chapter
number two, the cow. Surah al-Imran,
chapter number three, the family of
Imran. Surah an-Nisa, chapter number
four, the women. Surah al-Ma'idah,
chapter number five, the table spread.
Surah al-An'am, chapter number six, the
cattle. Surah al-A'raf, chapter number
seven, the heights. Surah al-Anfal,
chapter number eight, the spoils of war.
Surah at-Tawbah, chapter number nine,
the repentance. Surah Yunus, chapter
number 10, the prophet Jonah. Surah
Surah Hud, chapter number 11, the
prophet Hud. Surah Surah Yusuf, chapter
number [clears throat] 12, prophet
Joseph. Surah
Surah ar-Ra'd, chapter number 13, the
thunder. Surah al-Ibrahim, the chapter
number 14, prophet Ibrahim. Surah
al-Hijr, chapter number 15, the rocky
tract. Surah an-Nahl, chapter number 16,
the bee. Surah al-Isra, number 17, the
night journey. Surah al-Kahf, chapter
number 18, the cave. Surah Maryam,
chapter number 19, Mary. Surah Taha,
chapter number 20, Arabic letters Taha.
Surah al-Anbiya, chapter number 21, the
prophets. Surah al-Hajj, chapter number
22, the the holy pilgrimage. Surah al-
Surah al-Mu'minun, chapter number 23,
the believers. Surah an-Nur, chapter
number 24, the light. Surah al-Furqan,
chapter 25, the criterion. Masha Allah,
takbir. Allahu Akbar. Takbir. Allahu
Akbar. Takbir. Allahu Akbar.
1 minute
1 minute 3 seconds.
1 minute 3 seconds for
first 25.
Alhamdulillah. Who can make it less than
1 minute 3 seconds?
You are in the fast train now.
Bullet train is less than a minute.
Who can do faster than
1 minute 3 seconds?
Insha Allah, who can do it?
Less than 1 minute 3 seconds.
No, your time is over.
Second time, no.
When you go home, do your homework. How
fast can I do it? How fast can I do it?
Increase the speed. The faster, the
better.
Who can do it less than 1 minute 3
seconds? Insha Allah, raise your hand.
We have less time. Who can do it? Insha
Allah.
One. You want to try?
You want to try, sir?
Okay, we'll give three people a chance.
Brother Fadli.
Arsh.
And brother Farooq, okay.
Rattle off. Bullet train, Insha Allah.
Surah al-Fatiha, Surah number one, the
opening.
Surah al-Baqarah, Surah number two, the
the heifer. Surah number three, Al
Imran, family of Imran. Surah number
four, An-Nisa, Surah Surah Surah
An-Nisa, chapter number four.
Surah to
Ma'idah,
Surah number five.
>> [snorts]
>> Surah to An'am,
as
the uh Surah number six,
the cattle. Surah to Al-A'raf, the
heights. Surah number seven. Surah to
Anfal, the Surah number eight, the
spoils of war.
Surah to Tawbah, Surah
number chapter number nine.
Surah to
Yunus,
prophet Jonah.
Surah to Hud, prophet Hud.
Surah to Yusuf, prophet Joseph. Surah to
Ra'd, the thunder. Surah to
Ibrahim, chapter number 14. Surah to
Hijr,
chapter 15, the rocky tract.
Surah to
Surah
16.
Surah to 17, Surah Isra, the night
journey. Surah to 16,
Surah to Nahl,
chapter 16. Surah to
Okay, Surah to Nahl.
Surah to Hijr, Surah to Nahl, Surah to
Isra, number 17, chapter 17. Surah to
Surah to Kahf,
>> [snorts]
>> chapter
18. Surah to
Maryam, Mary, 19.
Surah to Taha, the two Arabic letters
Taha. Surah
Surah to
Anbiya, the prophets.
Surah to Hajj, the pilgrimage. Surah to
Al-Mu'minun, the believers. Surah to
An-Nur, the light. And Surah to Furqan,
the criterion, number 25.
How many did you miss?
How many did you not mention?
No one is paying attention.
How many
words did he miss out of 50?
How many?
27?
Out of 50, one is Surah name, one is
meaning.
Out of the 50 words, how many did he not
say?
How many?
How many did he not say?
He did not say three.
Out of that also, he did not say in
order.
Who is better? Somebody you know the
brother Fadli.
Brother Fadli is better or somebody you
know?
Who knew better? Brother Fadli or
somebody you know?
Somebody you know said in order. I
interrupted him in between.
But he specifically said in order.
For the first effort, it is masha Allah,
very good.
Otherwise, for the train competition,
tried bullet train, became train, slow
train, bus, car.
Cut.
How many minutes? I didn't ask.
2 minutes 26 seconds. So, when you go
home, you practice.
And when you practice, you come to know
your own self.
The target was
less than 1 minute
3 seconds.
You achieved 2 minutes
26 seconds with missing three.
Now, what do you have to do?
Go back and test on my own self, Insha
Allah.
How?
What do you have to do?
Revision.
Surah al-Ankabut, chapter number 29,
verse number 69. Your next homework.
Yes, sir. Insha Allah. Surah al-Ankabut,
chapter number 29. After Furqan, you go
to Surah al-Ankabut, after four Surahs.
Ankabut, the spider.
Remember the spider? Yes.
Surah of the spider.
Two people remaining.
Okay.
Arsh.
Okay, Arsh, you are ready? Time is up.
You start any part. Eyes.
Let's take, huh? Actually, the the way I
have learned so that tongue would gets
twisted off when I say that.
>> That we will check afterwards also, how
good are you in your way. First, you try
my way. Insha Allah.
Okay, first you try my way.
You want to be as good as you are as
good as I am? As you are. You want to be
better than me, Insha Allah. Insha
Allah. The more my students
do better, I'm happy. If they come close
to me, I'm happy, but they excel better
than me, I'm more happy because I'll get
sawab.
So, then I can relax, okay, somebody is
there who's taking my place.
Otherwise, you know, we want someone to
sawab e jariya. Our beloved prophet
Muhammad said that when you die, your
account closes except for three things.
The wealth you have spent.
And it gets ajar for you.
The knowledge
gets sawab for you and your children who
pray for you.
The knowledge, little bit I want, even
after I die, I want the sawab e jariya.
So, Insha Allah, I want
you good brothers, you call students or
participants to be sawab e jariya for
me. Yes.
Arsh.
Surah al-Fatiha, chapter number one, the
opening. Surah al-Baqarah, chapter
number two, the heifer, the cow. Surah
Al Imran, chapter number three, the
family of Imran. Surah An-Nisa, chapter
number four, the women. Surah
al-Ma'idah, chapter number five, the
table spread. Surah al-An'am, chapter
number six, the cattle. Chapter number
Surah al-A'raf, chapter number seven,
the heights. Surah al-Anfal, chapter
number eight, the spoils of war. Surah
at-Tawbah, chapter number nine, the
repentance. Surah Yunus, chapter number
10, prophet Jonah. Chapter number Surah
Hud, chapter number 11. Surah
prophet Hud, chapter Surah
Surah Yusuf, chapter number 12. Surah
Joseph, chapter Surah Ra'd, chapter
number 13, the the thunder. Surah
al-Ibrahim, chapter number 14, the
prophet Ibrahim. Surah chapter Surah
Hijr, chapter number 15, The Rocky
Tract. Chapter number Surah Nahl,
chapter number 16, The Nahl The Bee.
Surah Isra, The Night Journey. Surah
Isra, chapter number
17, The Night Journey. Chapter number 18
Surah Kahf, chapter number 18, The Cave.
The Surah Maryam, chapter number 20
chapter number 19,
The Mary. Surah Taha, chapter number 20,
Arabic letter Taha. Surah Anbiya,
chapter number 21, The Prophets. Surah
Hajj, chapter number 22, The Pilgrimage.
Surah Mu'minun, chapter number 23, The
Believers. Surah Nur, chapter number 24,
The Light. Surah Furqan, chapter number
25, The Criterion. Takbir. Allahu Akbar.
What was the timing? More than 1 minute,
I know that. 1 minute, how many seconds?
1 minute 11 seconds, close to the fast
train.
We'll come to you. We'll ask you to say
your style also. First, I want the style
I'm saying. And then we'll ask others,
whichever style you want, you can say.
Okay, last try, Farik.
Let's see if we can improve.
You can do it in less than 1 minute.
Can you do it in less than 1 minute?
Inshallah. Inshallah.
>> helps me. Allah helps you. So, let's see
if Allah is going to help you or not.
Surah Fatiha, chapter number one, The
Opening. Surah Baqarah, chapter number
two, The Cow. Surah Al Imran, chapter
number three, The Family of Imran. Surah
Nisa, chapter [clears throat] number
four, The Women. Surah Ma'idah, chapter
number five, The Table Spread. Surah
An'am, chapter number six, The Cattle.
Surah A'raf, chapter number seven, The
Heights. Surah Anfal, chapter number
eight, The Spoils of War. Surah Tawbah,
chapter number nine, The Repentance.
Surah Yunus, chapter number 10, Prophet
Jonah. Surah Hud, chapter number 11,
Prophet Hud. Surah
Surah Yusuf, chapter number 12, Prophet
Joseph. Surah Ra'd, chapter number 13,
The Thunder. Surah
Ibrahim, chapter number 14, Prophet
Ibrahim. Surah Hijr, chapter number 15,
The Rocky Tract. Surah Nahl, chapter
number 16, The Bee. Surah Isra, chapter
number 17, The Night Journey. Surah
Kahf, chapter number 18, The Cave. Surah
Maryam, chapter number 19, Mary. Surah
Taha, chapter number 20, Arabic letter
Taha. Surah Anbiya, chapter number 21,
The Prophets. Surah Hajj, chapter number
22, The Pilgrimage. Surah Mu'minun,
chapter number 23, The Believers. Surah
Nur, chapter number 24, The Light. Surah
Furqan, chapter number 25, The
Criterion.
Takbir.
Don't give the time. What do you think
was the time?
35 seconds, 40 seconds.
40 seconds.
Who did not time? Who did not time him,
raise your hand.
Would anyone like to guess what was his
timing?
Was it less than 1 minute or more than 1
minute?
Less. How less?
46 seconds.
Takbir.
Takbir. Takbir.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allahu Allahu Ya Rabbi Ya Allahu